هذا وقد خلت فنلندا عن عقود من عدم
الانحياز العسكري وقررت لانضمام الى
الناتو في مايو الماضي واعلنت فنلندا عن
استثمارات عسكريه كبرى وذلك منذ بدء حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا يعتبرها الناتو حصنا
قويا على ضفته الشماليه الشرقيه
وتمتلك فنلندا حدودا مشتركه بطول الفين
وثلاثمائه واربعين كيلو مترا مع روسيا
وتملك واحدا من اقوى الترسانات من قطع
المدفعيه في اوروبا فنلندا اصبحت الدوله
السابعه اذا من دول البلطيق وعلى بحر
البلطيق وهو ما يعني المزيد من العزله
للمدخل الساحلي لروسيا عند مدينه سانت
بطرسبرج وعلى جيبها الصغير في كالينغراد
وبمجرد انضمام فنلندا الى الحلف ستتضاعف
حدود الناتو مع روسيا الى اكثر من الضعف
لتصل الى حوالي 2500 كم
يعتبر انضمام فنلندا الى الناتو اذا اسرع
انضمام لدوله جديده الى الحلف على الاطلاق
فنلندا ستتلقى ضمانات قويه بموجب الماده
الخامسه من معاهده الناتو وهي مبدا الدفاع
الجماعي بمعنى ان اي هجوم على اي احدى او
احدى الدول الاعضاء يعامل على انه هجوم
عليها جميعا ومع انضمام فنلندا الى الناتو
ستتمتع الولايات المتحده بوصول كامل الى
البنيه التحتيه العسكريه للبلاد وبالنسبه
الى روسيا يعتبر انضمام فنلندا نكسا
استراتيجيه كبيره لها فقد ارسلت روسيا
جيشها الى اوكرانيا العام الماضي على امل
الحب من توسع الناتو لكن ما تحقق هو العكس
تماما